recording yeah okay hey guys we're back
after a double round yesterday pretty
rough day for me decent day for you
chess is tough and it's tiring I'm I was
exhausted at the beginning this
tournament due to jet lag and I'm
exhausted due to chess hmm
so yeah uh but hopefully I have some
instructive moments to share from
yesterday definitely some painful
moments but um at least my my first loss
yesterday it was against the top seed
grandmaster have no idea how to ground
pronounce his name
moreover you andre from romania and he
beat me Mario Mario there's a lot of
yeah he beat me pretty swiftly it was
like if you just take a class of the
game it seems like he just crushed me
even though I thought I was better at
some points
he got a very officious attack and then
I just collapsed
so we'll take a look at the opening I
attempted to surprise him on move one by
playing E 5 because I normally play
Sicilian time on off but after seeing
some of us some of your Kansas I was a
bit scared to go into this and C's
Romanian players yeah sharp stuff so we
went into some Italian variation you
played Bishop c4 I was expecting the
Scotch but I had to be prepared for
anything so this is a line that I I
teach my students with this early a6
idea to play Bishop a7 and just stay
flexible so he was taking more time than
me in the opening which gave me some
confidence because this is still
preparation and then he played this move
which i think is a secondary move I
haven't had a chance to check the
database but you played h3 here which I
think usually White Castle earlier or
pretty sure castling is Amin
but h3 is interesting because he's
staying flexible he might want to play
g4 also keeping the option open if not a
flaw in him right so I started thinking
here and I played what seemed like a
natural move rookie eights and then he
surprised me I was expecting him just to
Castle and have some some more mainline
but he played the immediate night f1
mm-hmm
I actually had a student who played a
very similar line recently in which my
student played some move like d6 in this
position and I had gone over the game
with her and told her that the the most
thematic move here is not to play d6 but
to play d5 right just to try and open
the center when white is slow to Castle
so that's what I did I was feeling
pretty happy because now I have threats
of of course taking on e4 and there's
some line here like if white takes on d5
take 93 I would be very happy to play
not f4 and this is one of the instances
where white kind of regrets not castling
really enough as I'm attacking g2 in d3
and this is already a really really nice
position if you're black right so I
think I showed my student like the same
line just a few weeks ago but my
opponent played a good move in this
position Queen e2 keeping all the
tension making sure the the file doesn't
open up and then I wasn't sure what to
do here I mean it seems like blacks
should be very fine
I mean I'm completed with development
but I wasn't sure how to like make use
of kind of temporary advantage yeah but
you know this is this is a known line I
think I really watched the DVD my uh by
tibia cuff who plays uh this kind of
stuff with white uh-huh and he was
recommending this early night off one
without castling interesting as just
like I mean objectively the black is
definitely fine but it's like just a
really aggressive way for white to play
this position because he's trying to
develop the King side attack first
exactly and then keep his options open
so you can Castle queenside I feel like
it is dangerous if you're not prepared
here with some like concrete idea
of how to deal with it maybe that's a
problem is I I was on my own here and I
should probably learn this position a
bit deeper as I play the move here which
made sense at the time but I think it
turned out to be a mistake just move h6
I just wanted to prevent any sort of
possibilities with Bishop g5 at night g5
the problem which will see very soon is
it a lot of this potential hook in the
position is that if he goes for G 45 it
just it's so much stronger in the
position and that's what he went for g4
so I'm thinking maybe I had some
different move I don't know just some
improving that I would like to like I
wanted to play Bishop e6 but then he
plays my g5 that's a bit annoying right
so I don't know maybe I can play like b5
and just improve and see what he does
even Knight a5 and then go for some b5
play anyway I played six yeah I didn't
think it was it should be that bad for
me but he played g4 and then then I
started thinking his g5 is a really
annoying threat mhm
just opening with G file getting a
Bishop to g5 so I took a long think here
and I found nothing that satisfied me I
started with 95 after the game he was
saying something who saying that if I
was the wrong move he was saying I
should play b5 I'm not sure if that
makes any sense
no because g5 g 5 is coming yeah I mean
one plan for block is to play like b5
before try to fight for the d4 square
right and then if Y just leaves upon and
c3 then well you won't be able to Castle
queenside in the long long run but yeah
it's really tough to play this I feel
good cuz White's plays very simple right
just Ricci one g5 93 Knight f5 and and
you know all you have to find some kind
of concrete idea to create counter play
exactly which didn't really manage to
find in the game think about
age seven maybe so that's what I
eventually did yeah that's why I played
95 originally and when I played 95 I had
to I had two possibilities I knew he was
gonna play Bishop c2 and then I did bait
I was debating here between nine eight
seven and Bishop e6 I really wanted to
make Bishop e6 work the problem is I
think he just can take on e5 I ended up
rejecting this line but if I play Bishop
e6 take oh really I think so like it
seemed wrong I spent so much time trying
to find something concrete here for
black but I think he just gets away with
winning upon I wanted to take take and
then Bishop d5 idea if pawn take defy
quint 85 when I hit the rook on each one
but then he like I'm only attacking the
knight here he can play something like
well first of all I was calculating f4
and then I wanted to take taken f6 I
thought this would be good for black
yeah and that's what I originally
thought when I play Knight a5 is this
line and oh looks it looks really nice
for black and open the center I went out
material yeah
but then after he played Bishop c2 I
realized he doesn't have to play out for
he can play Bishop at 4 and he's just
defending he's ready to put a rook on d1
and he has everything defended I'm not
winning anything right I can't even play
like Bishop c4 cousin I take c4 do you
have yeah I don't see anything here do
you have other options other than Bishop
d5 I was looking at like 97 it just
seems to simplify and he's just up upon
and he has so many ideas like between
putting a rock on Jiwon or just a chi 3
and castling or even Bishop e3 just
going for simplifications so yeah yes
yeah I mean I'm I have to check with the
engine I've been making an effort this
tournament not to check any games with
engine just because I I want to UM I
don't want to be lazy but
I think this is a type of position I
spent so long I couldn't find anything
you know what if you put the bishop on
d7 to keep the e5 pawn protected there's
57 here yeah I was just scared of g5
because if you like it so hard so needs
probably wait can you take on e4 and
play Bishop b5 ah intermediate move
take take Bishop b5 maybe that's
possible yeah that would actually be
nice I didn't consider this intermediate
idea I mean you could take on e4 alt
first also I imagine and then Bishop d7
maybe he can play a move like a four and
just restrict but I have this idea one
so here let's say you take on e4 and
then play Bishop e6 because now 95 you
ever should be three uh I actually had a
game like this once against um Mammadov
uh-huh and the computer pointed out this
idea in prep like Bishop d7 and
therefore there should be 60 of these
nuances yeah I would have never found
over the leg it's so hard to find over
the board like these small details
actually was really funny because um
because I got this prepping against him
and I was better and then once we were
out of prep he just completely outplayed
me well and then after the game he had
no idea I prepared that he thought I was
just playing badly nobody was like in
the opening he's like oh yeah you played
very well in the opening with an f-15
not so much it's felt like that's what
happened to me in this game like I
thought I built up like I should be
better here giving like he's he's so
slow to develop I'm fully developed yeah
I just didn't find the right ideas I I
play this move nine eight seven which is
not the move I wanted to play but I
wanted to prepare against g5 and I
thought it would still be a game but I
think from this moment forward he just
had all the momentum going in his favor
and the the play just came so easily for
a white like the the rest of the game
it's just like all flow for the white
side night
three I wanted to bring my Knight to g6
or eise Ickx but he goes for the
immediate break g5 we traded on g5 I
play a six which it's weakening but had
to chase away the bishop calmly drops
back to d2 and like visually it looks
okay for black because a tack for white
isn't isn't yet so threatening but you
just wants to play rook g1 in like
Knight h5 and g7 is actually a annoying
target to defend because he has so much
potential to attack it with the rook the
knight and Bishop later on and that's
what we'll see yeah so I take and put my
bishop on e6 and now actually I based
this whole idea like taking in Bishop e6
on a miscalculation
because after rook g1 I played Bishop c4
and I I thought like yes to play Queen
d1 and then nothing was gonna play
something like Bishop f7 by completely
missed his next move and after his next
move he's just crushing me
so black there white to move find the
alternative instead of Queens e1 okay
yeah cuz I was also I was like oh wow
that's a nice idea when I just
completely missed it there should be
three I can't take this Queen I can't
even take his I can't play Knight take
me three because Queen takes c4 wins the
piece and if Bishop take b3 he just he
can take with the a pawn and I can't
take him on b3 cuz Queen c4 check and he
keeps initiative and then he's attacking
my 1985 he's ready to play 9 h5 yeah
yeah so Bishop e3 is just crushing me I
played what I thought was the only tries
to play b5 but then he he played in like
very nice attacking technique he just
trades and castles Queen side because
King is completely safe my knight is a
decoration on c4 it's not doing anything
rooks on d1 like the fact that his both
rooks are on these half open file and
open file targeting my queen
my king it's it's so sad 9h 5 is coming
Bishop h6 is coming so I tried to pull
up resistance
I only resisted for 8 moves and then he
made it me
so ok g6 I guess like for 4 people
watching this this is kind of a nice
attacking game from the white side the
fact that he was able to make use of the
hook open the G file and then just get
so much initiative especially from this
position started with simple move Knight
h4 already ideas of night 8 g6 and
Knight f5 and Queen h5 or queen g4
coming so I play the sad move King no 7
and Bishop h6 every move felt like a
punch in the face well because like he's
attacking my queen he's attacking my
nights like Queenie 7 another punch in
the face night GF 5 it's good title for
the video when every move feels like a
punch in the face yeah it's yeah it's
it's not a great feel
first of all I can't take the Knights
cuz I might just got body slams Queen h5
and then he just takes with mates
so I I mean I thought I tried like I did
my best to complicate things like at
least I'm counter attacking f2 but now
he takes on that fate and g6 has no
defenders then after I played Queen take
f2 he started thinking and I actually
felt okay I knew I was probably gonna
lose but I felt like he may have
overlooked this given that his bishop is
hanging his knight still hanging his
queen is now attacked I have ideas with
Queen take g1 also have mating idea it's
like if he plays Queen b3 I just meet
him so I like any endgame you're gonna
be winning the bishop back so you're
right gonna be okay so though I guess
this is a good exercise for whites
let me just client delete the oh yeah
just on the sound area oh wow I never
knew that okay it's good to know yeah
this is a good exercise from the white
site like white to move and just destroy
black so White's a plain one yes
I won't make you solve it you probably
already see the notation no I saw the
game okay it was so the whole idea for
why just ignore everything that's
hanging and just go for the attack
against the king rook d7 check I don't
think I can take on that fake because
then he starts doing things to me so I
take Heaney six
and that's incredible like almost all
his pieces are hanging like both rooks
know every piece is under attack
yeah like knight or niche for yeah and
it's still like b2 yes anyone who says
oh just defend all your pieces is wrong
that's not it's not chess yeah but now
okay he plays amazing move and I think
this move is simple to play given that
okay my Kings on e6 it has no squares to
move to just plays rook gt1 and now he
just has a simple threat of Knight g7
mates and what to do
and if I take the knight he takes back
with pawn and he wins so I was about to
resign here but then I wanted to play on
one more move 96 because still like all
his pieces are hanging yeah and now he
plays another simple move rook takes c7
and he's threatening me on g6 and me and
on g7 right and then I let him make me
Queen take I won this Queen at least I
made it so this one with the rook seven
I think 97 is it's too risky because I
don't know you might overlook something
for the rook on d6 it's defended twice
more clear checkmate exactly it was
pretty brutal but at least I lost
quickly I had time to rest before the
next round which I also lost but yeah I
mean this is at least an instructive
attacking game I clearly did not
understand the position resulting from
the opening I think this is going to be
a position to look back on I'm sure
there's some theory here and yeah after
we finish recording I'll probably go and
check the database
how come in this position has occurred
and see see where if I if I had any
advantage and all they could have done
differently you know
so anyway shall we move on to some
happier happier notes
sure well I ended up winning in round
six
I was playing white against candidate
master by the name of Drago's Daniel
Martian it's like 2200 and so I checked
his games and he has a very narrow
repertoire and I'm mainly a d4 player
but against efore he was exclusively
playing the Khan so I felt comfortable
to go into it I loved doing that against
people with narrow repertories yeah it's
fine like some opening you can prepare
and you know exactly what to expect
especially since he does not have a lot
of experience playing insta line with g3
which I recommend in my book and I've
studied a lot most of the games that
were like Bishop d3 which is one of the
main lines or c4 mm-hmm and he seems
like a very solid player so I think he's
very comfortable and he's like Hedgehog
type positions by the way I had a
student who messaged me yesterday and
like he he's been watching our videos
and he like realized like within the
last day that you're the one who wrote
that the modernized Sicilian book so he
just says hi and says thank you oh
that's awesome well yeah I mean so this
is um for those who don't know it's a
book I wrote with international master
Ronnie Beck come on of and I actually
don't have experience as an e4 player
but he does he's been playing it so you
wrote it as a white repertory book
exactly a white repertoire for strictly
the open Sicilian nice and nothing else
so is a huge research project for me
because I've never played any of these
lines sure and I've always been a player
that's kind of afraid of these
double-edged positions because you know
things can go wrong for a white very
easily here but okay writing that book I
think did great things from my own chest
because it introduced me to all kinds of
new ideas okay well he sticks to kind of
the main way black plays this position
which has been
should be for inducing Bishop d2 knight
c6 attacking the knight I have to pull
back Knight f6 Bishop g2 and castles
castles and now Bishop e7 so this is a
normal move because he wants to retreat
before he plays d6 otherwise it just
gets hit with a three he had a game like
this once before and I think he missed
played it it wasn't this exact move
order but white side the end this line
is actually extremely aggressive the
point is to play f4 and g4 very very
quickly and then we're trying to play g5
lift the rook to h3 bring the Queen to
h5 or h4 if black plays g6 and white
just gets a very very strong attack in
that game I don't think it was this
exact move order but he played this move
h6
which is a very very double-edged move
blacks ideas if he played g5 he can
force you to give up your pawn on f4 and
then his Knights get the e5 score which
is an extremely useful optically this
looks good for white but it's
surprisingly difficult to to checkmate
here because the knight on e5 controls
f3 and comes to g6 and just so many good
squares so h6 is a very useful move but
the main drawback generally speaking in
Sicilians is that when Y plays h4 the
attack is now a lot stronger because you
have this hook it's the same theme and
from the previous game yeah yeah exactly
and so sometimes but I can get away with
this there's some nitrous when you can
do this but I think if you Castle and
play h6 super early it's very dangerous
I mean house you have to be very very
accurate okay in this game I started
with a 3 I'm not exactly sure why I
could have played out for I think maybe
I was wondering if he's gonna go for
some d5 line I just wanted to see how
him show his cards because a3 is gonna
be the response to b5 anyway so it's
kind of useful move okay he plays d6 f4
we kind of transpose back into normal
lines b5 g4 and here he plays 97 so it's
a typical move he's planning on
transferring the night to
six and c4 and the main way for white to
play is again g5 and if 96 sometimes why
could even just play f5 and just trying
to play f6 I mean this position again it
looks optically good but why does not
that close to just meaning here you
still have to develop the attack and
block is very very solid and we've given
up the e5 square so very double-edged
position still I decided to go for a
different plan Queen e2 and the idea
here is just extremely prophylactic
after Knight b6 I want to play rook 81
and Knight c4 I'm ready to meet with
Bishop c1 that's nice just like limit
black screen side play before you go for
the King side attack exactly and I think
the knight on c4 actually it's similar
to the knight in your game it's just a
decoration I mean not necessarily it is
it's definitely putting pressure on
White's position so I always have to
watch out for 1983 right and it's I mean
hitting e3 it's ready to jump to e5 but
it is in the way a little bit because
now black can't play be for the knight
danger and he also doesn't have the
pressure on the C file when this night
is always on c4 but White's bishop on c1
is defending the weakness and is always
ready to include itself in the King side
mm-hmm
in the long term if my knight can never
get to d4 I also have this idea of
playing b3 Bishop b2 so I felt
interesting I felt like it was an
interesting position here okay he plays
h6 which we saw or I said he did in the
other game as well I think it's dubious
here too sometimes you can pick up on
little things that your opponents do
like if they make a positional mistake
in one game they're sometimes likely to
repeat in other games which is
interesting he should have done
according to the engine Queen b6 check
in a5 and here you get some counter play
with b4 apparently white has this 95
move where the bishop on e7 will be
hanging another benefit of putting the
Queen on e2 is that you always have this
95 idea things would be a mess I'm not
sure if I would have gone for a 95 or
not but
that would be I think that was the
better way for black to play okay he
plays h6
and actually here I really should have
taken a time out with King h1 just to
get out of the way of Queen b6 I ended
up going with rig d3 which is a thematic
idea I can't really play h4 here because
of the bishop but I had the second plan
to put the rook on h3 and then play g5
Queen h5 so again he should have given
check and played a 5
or even a 5 right away might be stronger
using this common trick that I can't
take the pawn because of Queen b6 check
in 84 and g5 and he's killing me on this
diagonal yeah my first chess coach
because I used to play open sicilians
when I was much younger and my first
chess coach said King h1 is always a
typical Sicilian move especially when
the pawns on that for you should play
King h1 instinctively yeah it's a very
very useful move so I feel like I miss
played the position a little bit but
fortunately he didn't he didn't punish
me with this a5 idea which would have
been really strong he plays kind of more
normal Bishop b7 rook h3 Rickey 8 and g5
I mean here I felt good but I wasn't
sure exactly how good it was so of
course he can't take Queen h5 is and
that wasn't that the whole point of
playing h6 was to take and get the e5
square right so well it seems like it
kind of backfired
yeah now black has has issues because
white is ready to take on h6 and start
opening things up but he has this
typical idea he just plays Bishop f8 and
this point is that G takes h6 he's gonna
play g6 and just try to keep things as
closed as possible and I spent a lot of
time trying to figure out this position
it's a very thematic one black does this
thing kind of a lot mm-hmm it's usually
a what's the right term like a last
resort where like if they have no other
way of getting counter play they can't
you know stop the attack they're just
gonna give the pawn try to blockade with
the King on h7 and say it's hard for
white to break through because whenever
I push that five here he again gets the
e5 square unfortunately I really miss a
evaluated this position because
sometimes this is working for black but
here's just a really good version for
white so how do I just play it f5
let's say 95 each takes f5 is definitely
possible but a lot of times it runs into
95 which hits the Queen and things get
very risky for black so more likely 95
would be played and then I can play move
like King h1 I can also take first and
then play King h1 and I think what I
miss evaluated here is that in the final
position I wasn't sure how exactly I'm
gonna be adding the pressure because his
plan is pretty clear King h7 he might
put a rook on the seventh rank it just
seems like all the entry scores are
covered I don't see any potential
sacrifices any breakthroughs but I was I
was playing around and the engine loves
this for white I mean like we're talking
+3 Wow
and so the plan that it points out is
just putting the knight on d4 to put
pressure on e6 in some cases threatening
Rick f6 and then switching the rook to
g3 and playing Bishop h3 mm-hmm which is
very strong that's interesting yeah as
sometimes it's a matter of like
identifying one target that you can
attack multiple times i guess ii six
isn't the most obvious target in this
position yeah you would think g6 or
trying to play h4 h5 yeah and I just
felt like well not seeing a really clear
plan to improve my position you kind of
panic with white because if your attack
stalls out positionally black is much
better understandable like you've
committed your f5 given the e5 square so
yeah but that was that was definitely a
Miss evaluation because what I realized
later in the game that I failed to
realize here is that he actually has
very little counter play hmm and this is
the trade-off that block has to think
about in the in the Sicilian because
sometimes they can make a lot of
defensive moves and
you from getting your attack in but then
they still don't get their own
counterplay going right once they do
start trying to create counterplay then
the attack becomes stronger like in many
of these positions black tries to play
move like 95 which is obviously going to
be very harmful for the King side attack
but at the same time creating threats so
yeah in any case I I decided to play
King h1 I wanted to keep the tension
longer
he plays Queen b6 so again if I take on
h6 I think this position is really good
for white do you consider it take on h66
mm-hmm there's an idea rook g3 and then
h4 h5 yeah definitely essentially I felt
that let's say he plays like King h7h
Ford I felt like he's just gonna put the
knight on e7 at some point mm-hmm and it
looked really hard to break through this
kind of position in h5 yeah I just want
to like continue adding pressure maybe
even like triple up on the G file Bishop
on h3 work on g1 yeah definitely I mean
definitely seems very very possible if
you attempt to break through without
giving away the e5 square right very
right just keeping the pawn on f4 I
would imagine block really needs to to
try something like d5 just to get
counter play yeah maybe it gets messy so
yeah if you can get away with this then
it's very double-edged if not then yeah
I definitely make sense but something
like this is what I was well trying to
just keep in mind that things can turn
very quickly
mm-hmm but yeah I was definitely
considering all of these ideas I'm sure
event I mean what I decided was to just
start doubling on the G file so before
designing the structure because from his
point of view if he plays g6 without me
taking the additional option I have is I
have Erick takes h6 and some ideas like
that so one line that I thought might
happen was I could play out five here
and if he takes on
five I have 95 Knight of six check I'm
thinking even like a quiet move here
something like Queen f2 I was trying to
calculate the running rook takes in
Queen h4 so it's very very risky for him
to to do this okay buddy I think he he
does the right thing Rick a c8 I played
Bishop f3
now I'm also having the additional
threat of playing queen g2 and then Rick
takes age sex with this discovered
attack nice okay so here he plays g6 and
now it's a critical moment I felt like
if I play a five now he can't take
ninety five I think is strong he will
probably play Knight e5 and I wasn't
quite sure how to how to evaluate this
because he wants to take on f3 and take
this important bishop and then break
with d5 there's so much tension in this
position yeah it felt very easy very
unclear and yeah I honestly just have no
idea I don't think I checked this with
the engine too carefully but um yeah
that kind of scared me I wanted to keep
the pawn on f4 so I decided to kind of
go with your plan take King h7 rip g3
nice although I think the entrance is
all like cell 5 but okay he plays Bishop
e7 and I was considering all kinds of
ideas here like Bishop h5 just trying to
just sacrifice and open things up and
actually this is very very close to
working um there was one line I was able
to calculate I not sure exactly why I
rejected this but okay rook Jade is
forced if he takes this is just gonna be
me because I have rook g7 Czech Queen
takes f7 because King has no defenders
yeah it's just it's just game over I
mean I also have I think Queen g2 is
actually simpler mm-hmm this is just a
very common mating pattern that everyone
needs to know put three pieces on the G
file and then Rick h7 check and mate so
this is very dangerous he would have to
just try and protect then I can play a
five and now if he takes on f5 or on h5
or on f5 first if he takes on h5 and
then I can just trade everything Queens
you two in the end and yeah Queen comes
to g2 and it's just the mate um are you
promote King f8 Queen g7 and h7 yeah are
the H upon promotes in all these lines
exactly and if he plays 95 I can take on
g6 and then just break through this way
hmm
because your pitch it defends h6 exactly
nice my bishop is defending h6 and so in
this key line white has to play queen g4
check in Queen h5 check not to allow
them to escape nice and then during the
game I saw this position I assumed it
was winning mm-hmm I checked a little
bit deeper and then the engine finds a
just amazing resource at the end here
I'll give people a chance to find it but
this would be the critical line and then
you didn't calculate this far no no I
assumed it would be good but in this
position white has exactly one winning
move but it's absolutely crushing it's
like plus 50 so if you guys want to
pause your video try to find the move
here that would be that would be a good
good training exercise I have an idea
and I have not cheated mm-hmm 95 95 yeah
just the most fanatic move I love that
the line ends with 95 great and either
block loses the Queen or gets mated
mm-hmm well what if the Queen like Queen
f2 it's covered ah she's defended yeah
and Queen a 7 a 7 probably or Queen D I
think white should be meeting here well
Queen da there's a knight I'm assuming
there's 94 Queen a sudden right they'll
be 94 if Queen a 7
[Music]
wait I think I see something night a
five-night ak5 night before and then I
yes King b6 Bishop III male if King c5
it's a nice man Bishop III I mean yeah
we're winning the Queen yeah yes exactly
I think actually we can even we can do
this too and king b6 Queen f2 I think we
went smooth backwards yes Jeremy a trick
c5 I like your way actually because we
get the bishop to you exactly
okay but yeah it's kind of impractical
there just to keep calculate you assume
it's hard to calculate such a strong
pawn but I ended up rejecting this
because I think after he got five I
wasn't exactly sure what to do here but
the engine finds some some forced win I
think just break through again and just
another long calculation it's winning
yeah or maybe I wasn't sure if he for
example this position I wasn't quite
clear if maybe he has another move
rather than just taking the rook mm-hmm
or if you can take the rook and then
maybe like win d8 or something but I I
assume white is just meaning by force
mm-hmm but yeah that was kind of my last
chance to really fight for the advantage
from here I ended up playing this move
Bishop g4 threatening a different
sacrifice to take on e6 and then take on
g6 and he plays a really strong move
Bishop h4 which I just underestimated so
he first dislodges my rook and then his
plan is to go back Bishop f6 and be very
solid here I kind of realized soups the
tightest is turning so I took on e6
almost out of desperation but it turns
out just just to be quite dubious okay
if he takes on e6 I think I can take on
g6 and this looks really good so I have
queen g4 coming as bishop historic g7 a
lot of mates if he takes on g3 you take
on f7
and everything is kind of collapsing for
Blackwell so he takes it the rook this
is critical I have the idea is to play
f5 so with tempo I'm hitting g6 and I
get 95 so of course if he just moves
back we get the same position and I
think I think white is just winning take
take take and if he takes on that five
Queen h5 looks just devastating
everything hanging everything with me g7
square is always very vulnerable so he
takes on g3 it took on e6 and here you
know if he if he just keeps the bishop
he keeps the piece why it truly just
doesn't have enough so as you know
semi-bluff because this position looks
quite scary but you know if if there's
no mate there's no mate and so black is
probably just gonna end up up a piece
here we have some ideas the knight can
come to d5 d6 pawn is not obvious how to
protect I guess he has 97 but then the
f8 square is always gonna be dangerous
or like Bishop g5 ideas this seems hard
to evaluate yeah I'm sure the Clery just
loves black upper piece right
practically I mean g6 looks hard to
defend
yeah and I'm turning rook takes g6 in
many positions so you know it's like
it's one of those things where well I
mean you have to take a risk at some
point otherwise you might just get worse
and no counter play which in the
Sicilian is definitely a nightmare so
it's definitely risk it ends up paying
off because he decides to just take back
on e6 give back the material but kind of
stabilize his position with 95 now
White's up a pawn black is good
positional compensation but black still
doesn't have a whole lot of counter play
yet and only here I realized that
actually if my knight can just somehow
get to d4 and put pressure on e6 then
he's gonna have a tough time
he's also threatening actually at this
point to play rook f8 and rook
- so I actually found the only way to
not get worse here because if block is a
lot to do this it could be bad I played
queen f1 so threatening Queen f6 and
stopping Brooke f8 he found the best
move rook c7 just trying to get to f7
Queen f8 leads nowhere just Rick f7 and
Queen g1 and what I realized here is
actually if we go into the endgame I
might not be better but I'm definitely
not worse because my Knights gonna come
to d4 he's gonna have to defend the e6
pawn and his knights on e5 and c4 are
great but yeah they're not attacking
anything so at first it looks great for
black like giving your pawn weaknesses
right but like you're a foreign and h6
pawn are pretty stable exactly this is
what happened no he didn't trade but I
think objectively he should be okay here
but yeah it's not I think why does kind
of should be pushing here so at least
slightly he plays queen c6 so he wants
to keep the Queen's on the board
I played h4 Queen the 8th and here the
game starts turning again now I really
regretted not playing 94 here just right
away I decided to play h5 and then
finally he pushes 85 and here I realized
oh my knight was on d4 this would be
impossible because then I would be
hitting b5 so I was kind of upset that I
lot of it this counter play because now
he wants to play b4 and I have a real
problem with my c4 pawn so I missed the
best move here I ended up playing Queen
d4 just to defend the pawn but Queen
genes who would have been a lot stronger
to defend the pawn this way and just
keep the d4 score open for the night
it's got to feel weird putting your
Queen and King on the same diagnose
edition as this yeah to be honest I
didn't even I didn't even see this what
was possible but that's the computer for
you just like no shame from a human
point of view especially now it's been a
complicated game right we're both gonna
be in time trouble very soon right
yeah it's but okay objectively that was
still that was still good
anyway Queen d4
Rick f7 the engine points out amazing
move g5 yes just like just fantastic
rook take G 509 f3 well no there's no so
Bishop g5 Queen comes to h5 with check
that's clear rook g5 the idea is just
Queen FA just infiltrate on the M mile
which you couldn't do before because I
would take on g6 with check and then
things get murky but here Black is just
winning well yeah I mean well yeah
amazing what can you say you played rook
f7 kind of more normal
I decided to play Knight d2 I figured
okay his Knights are superfluous but I
need to trade them off I can try to play
b3 I have to do something here Queen e7
he was trying to get to h4 I decide to
take on c4 I actually completely missed
this move as possible Knight f3 would
have been a lot stronger because he has
a problem with the g7 square and the g6
square so Knight takes f3 I take on g6
rook takes f3
I still take on g6 and I end up winning
the exchange nice and he has some checks
but the the rook and the king they kind
of they're okay they kind of hold
everything but okay I took on c4 he
throws in this check be c4 I take on g6
and I was very nervous in this position
because it looks like black has just
completely taken over the initiative I
mean fil Queen on h4 knight on g6 is
ready to give me so many nasty checks
this Bishop is a lot I mean the only
reason I'm surviving is cuz the knight
on c3 defends the e4 pawn I actually
think this knight on c3 it barely moves
but it's the the real MVP in the game I
found the only way Bishop g5 I have to
take control over some squares and Queen
takes c4 and now the knight is not only
defending e4 but also the e2 square and
the d1 square so it's dominating the
Queen on each face as for this reason I
can't take the d6 pawn because he'll
play
Bishop takes e4 and white can resign 94
Queen e2 checked and I'm getting mated
so Queen c4 is the only move I saw to
keep everything protected
he plays d5 which I think is okay I took
took Queen d4 and in this position is so
it's so weird I mean why does two pawns
up as bishop on b7 seems dead just fully
blockaded his Queen has no moves his
knight has no moves his rook has to
defend let's lie down yeah and I'm two
pawns up but I also have no way of
improving my position that's crazy
like even if I push everything this is
me for stuckness yeah I think it's like
you know it's a stalemate in like the
normal sense of the word neither side
can can do much he ends up going wrong
here and allowing me one idea that I was
hoping for the best move I think would
have been something like Bishop c8 where
he's potentially wanting to play rook f5
if my Queen moves and he's just
controlling some some light squares g4
h3 so this move white still has a hard
time moving as well because if I take
many yet he's allowed Queen e2 check of
course Queen takes d5 he does the old
switcheroo and
I cry so that would have been I think
holding for him somehow white is also
okay he plays Bishop a6 which is logical
now it's a good good puzzle white to
play find the only move to secure an
advantage well Bishop f1 looks a bit
scary or even like oh he can't play rook
F on
I didn't see like that you had a tough
game I just took a glance of the opening
I thought you just crushed him with your
attack but oh no no my game was murdered
on the truth yeah I guess I finished so
quickly and I just spent mostly time
crying yes Bishop f1 maybe isn't a
threat cuz Kim Ji Won
I really want to take on d5 but just
Bishop e7 that's big problem ah is it
just a matter of simplifying can you
just play Queen g1 I think there's
something wrong with Queen d1 I play
queen g4 same idea same idea I'm not
sure exactly what the problem is with
this move
maybe your knight gets maybe he just
takes and my knight is misplaced and he
can still get some counter play mm-hmm
way after Queen g4 I forced the trade of
Queens and I'm able to just get a to
pawn up in game so Bishop ca would have
stopped this or if he leaves his Bishop
on b7 he would have tea for your daddy
for the basics is like the ideal squares
for you yeah it was a huge mistake
obviously induced by time trouble I
think he's down to two minutes at this
point I think he's played the game quite
well considering he probably wasn't
super familiar with the middle game see
how queen g4 I forced him to trade if he
throws in the check it doesn't help him
miss bishop it just kind of misplaced
he played Bishop b7 here and then I
found the only move actually to secure
an advantage King g3 so it's really
happy with this part of my game the
technique was it was decent I get out of
the way of d4 check and then after rook
f1 I put the bishop on e3 covering g1
ready to blockade and and now I think
I'm consolidating so he tried Rick h1
Rick g5 hitting the d5 punch
Ricky one King f2 he goes back and now I
just took and I already calculated here
that after rook h2 check King g1 if he
takes on C - I'm just take giving Knight
of 6 check and you can't take the pawn
rook g2 and Rick takes g6 there's also
actually one
nice line I considered here at some
point if he had played how did this line
go so the game he plays rook takes h6
which is losing but he has no other
options at this point but there is one
idea I was considering during the game
that if if we somehow traded rooks and
the viewers will have to imagine this
but if we trade rooks my bishop is on e3
covering the pawn then I play Knight f6
check forcing King h8 if you ever moves
the knife from g6 I have this amazing
idea just to play Bishop c5 Bishop
effeciency sadly is just like paralyzed
yeah very nice I think it's actually
common idea and these opposite colored
bishop end games but normally there's a
king on h6 uh-huh you put all your
pieces on dark squares if the night is
far away he can't do anything nice it's
a nice winning idea okay he took and
then I had to be accurate here but it's
a good good time again to pause and try
to find the the cleanest one I think
there are multiple ways but I just
played Rick a5 threatening the rook and
Rick f7 check and it's it's game over he
tried Bishop c8 check and another
attacking and that was it
very nice yeah so a tough game but ok at
a certain point I had to find some some
decent moves yeah I know that's these
positions scare me like these sharp
Sicilian positions that's why it's why I
didn't play Sicilian my game but still
rather fortunate I didn't lose the game
which would have been pretty
embarrassing but that's the risk you
always take yeah so well we played two
games yesterday so I think we'll we'll
save other two games for another video
yeah and then we have around in about
four hours
so yeah I think well we'll leave it here
and then already tomorrow is the last
it's the last day of the tournament yeah
flying by so yeah stay tuned
also huge thank you to everyone who's
watching these videos and
grimed I passed 2,000 subscribers like
other day I wanted to do some
celebratory livestream but I didn't want
to risk it with the Internet's all right
maybe I'll do some celebration I like
3,000 or something oh very cool
so all right thanks anyway see you guys